la rabine merci à l'élite
à bientôt rallye au revoir alors en ce
moment en ce moment au mieux les
éliminatoires pour la coupe d'america en
ce moment peggy bouchet vient de
traverser l'atlantique à la rame
donc nous avons demandé à la fiancée de
l'atlantique d'être avec nous ce soir
pour en parler macif lance arthaud
bonsoir quand on sartre ou alors vous
suivez un petit peu les éliminatoires de
la de l'américain la coupe louis vuitton
j'ai davantage suivi peggy goussé al
ahram vite s'il vous plaît publication
diego pourtant hier oui c'est vrai
j'étais son dégoût mais bon je branche
plus là ça m'a jamais facile c'est de la
voile donc forcément ça m'intéresse mais
c'est assez loin de ce qu'on fait c'est
d'avoir ses traits c'était c'est très
technique ça concerne formule 1 un peu
noël de saint louis de la formule 1
c'est si on veut non c'est assez la
tactique c'est de la régate c'est la
tactique de régates sais pas c'est pas
de la lamal aventure quoi ouais et le
guichet alors passé c'est encore mieux
parce que bon c'est vrai qu'il faut être
apparemment il serait complètement
désespérée pour partir votre assez
atlantique à la rame et fait il y avait
seulement envie de passer l'an 2000 en
mer tranquille toute seule et elle avait
tenté la dernière fois dans fin il ya
deux ans de le faire et elle avait
chaviré au bout de soixante dix neuf
jours juste avant d'arriver en
guadeloupe cette fois ci a choisi
d'arriver en martinique et elle a réussi
c'est bien bien alors florence arthaud
bonsoir vous dans 57 et grandit dans le
xvième dans un an un quartier où on fait
le mur pour des institutions religieuses
pour pour sortir et alors à 17 ans j'ai
l'action vous êtes sûr très très grave
et fait sept tonneaux et passé six mois
à garches été défigurée et je sais pas
comment je vais vous étiez comment avant
de fuir se voit pas du tout un ton
différent sarto était défiguré ans y
habitent ifs
ça a été ma chance c'est vraiment cet
accident ça m'a permis de me sortir un
petit peu de 2 de mon milieu et puis de
ce qui m'était destinée parce que
c'était parti d'el harrach l'accident
non mais en fait c'était une période de
deux ans de convalescence où on va
passer tous les caprices parce qu'il
fallait surtout pas me contredire
ce qu'eads restait un peu coincé et en
fait j'avais rien faire ni au niveau des
études parce que j'étais pas très vive
intellectuellement et ni au niveau
sportif à part du bateau on m'a autorisé
à faire du bateau donc je suis parti
très assez atlantique
ensuite j'ai fait ma vérité à antibes
avec marc quinn ce qui faisait dire à
l'école de voile
ouais vous disais dit en parlant de
cette époque parfois je vais me cacher
pour pleurer c'était dur cet
apprentissage
ah oui pas de sas en mousse c'est
toujours c'est toujours difficile quand
quand on est mou sont faits tous les
sales boulots et on n'a aucun enfin
aucune récompense mais c'est comme ça
que le métier rentre alors 78 kg est la
benjamine dans la route du rhum c'est la
première route du rhum sont 18 mai la
première il m'a très bien aussi
et vous avez gagné votre surnom de
petite fiancée de l'atlantique en 90
vous battez l'oeuf en fait le record de
traversée de l'atlantique en solitaire
en août et à ce moment là y'a loïck
peyron qui dit en parlant de vous après
ce record
oui enfin ce record de l'atlantique
c'est seulement un convoyage retour un
peu rapide
la route du rhum si elle y participe
je vous assure qu'elle sera pas un
client sérieux vous avez revu depuis
deux jours et en novembre ou gagné la
route du rhum sur sur pierre premier
vous l'avez revue loïck peyron vous est
expliqué la tuer mais de 500 mo il ya
souvent des petits trucs qui peuvent
échapper comme ça temps en temps il ne
manque pas de me laisser un message sur
mon répondeur au tac est pas je voulais
pas dire ça quand vous gagnez la route
du rhum donc sur pierre premier et alors
là vous devenez une star évidemment
nationale j'ai retrouvé des papiers de
l'époque on disait de florence arthaud
la nana qui se découragent pas quand
sarah dos sa radio pardon tombe en
miettes et quand elle a une panne de
pilote automatique elle barre pendant 24
heures sur 24 pendant cinq jours mais
enfin pas 24 heures sur 24 ce bar est
barrée 20 22 heures sur 24 enfin 23
heures je dormais de trois demi heure
par jour et c'est vrai donc oui enfin ça
on va regarder des images de vos
victoires serge magnéto s'il vous plaît
excellent
m
dans ma peau
au rex bactéries
dans ce bac tu
bon
en sarthe et 590 belle revanche en tous
les cas sur sur le sort sur cet accident
qui vous avait cloué au lit quelques
années auparavant
là tout va bien et et c'est la
catastrophe on va voir si on peut voir
les images serge de la catastrophe sous
tes paupières de tram arrêt parfois je
lis ou je devine
la solitude est le bateau
pierre
dis comme rush et sur la lande
vosges pas tu te demandes
nous sommes bien arrivés rivière
chacun fait comme il est
chacun temple
mais sur le ciel clément
les oiseaux en partant
non seulement le coup dur pour toi en
faire tout ça s'est passé comment je ne
sais pas comment on veut arriver là quoi
et puis ensuite j'étais parti faire
j'étais parti faire une course autour du
monde y sont attendus que je rentre pour
finalement enregistré cette chanson
c'est et certaines épreuves à tirer pour
machines très fier d'avoir fait parce
que c'était beaucoup plus simple ne pas
verser l'atlantique en solitaire est sur
tous les plateaux c'était affreux même
si c'était du théâtre anglais comme une
sage je vais vraiment important une
épreuve terrible pour moi mais je suis
très fier de l'avoir fait vous regrettez
pas de l'avoir fait là parce que c'était
une épreuve
ouais bah oui ça c'est une époque bien
méchante et donc avec pierre bachelet
effectivement et là tout est fini la
société pierre premier qui était votre
sponsor avant le match qu avez vous
commencé à le briser une carrière comme
saint justin et alors là vous commencez
à galérer pour trouver un sponsor à
partir de ce cas et vous faites des non
sérieusement là vous avez du mal après
je sais pas j'ai pas passé beaucoup de
temps à chercher non plus j'ai profité
de cette petite interruption pour aller
naviguer sur le bateau des autres
finalement c'est pas c'est pas si
désagréable que ça on a tous les
avantages sans en avoir les
inconvénients et aussi le le poids et la
responsabilité d'un équipage un bâtiment
en construction qui est tout le temps à
moitié cassé et je fais ça depuis
maintenant
huit ans vous avez des courses vous avez
fait le figaro sur bel espoir oui
alors quand on vous parlait du figaro
vous dites toute façon en cause figurent
en solitaire plutôt que de rester à quai
je me suis mise au figaro bénéteau la
mer c'est mon gagne pas on vous dit ça
d'une façon un peu comme ça un peu blasé
un peu cynique et puis la même année
vous dites je souffre lorsque je ne
navigue pas donc naviguer sur un figaro
bénéteau est en fait j'ai essayé de
rester un peu à terre là l'hiver dernier
et si bon ça me ça me manque trop et
puis c'est vrai que c'est mon gagne pain
oui cet été vous faites quoi dans vous
faites le figaro là que ce soit fleury
michon fait lorient saint bar vous le
faites voile à lorient ça en double en
double avec philippe poupon ses vrais
amis sont puis ensuite sur la saison en
solitaire le seul quoi pour que rôle
solo suite la porte parole en
méditerranée et puis le figaro dans le
gaz et gascogne au milieu des j'ai
beaucoup florence arthaud je croirais
charmant mais tout à l'heure il m'a dit
ouais non beaucoup beaucoup je trouve
que c'est une personne humaine
magnifique et je le dis sans aucune
j'aimerais vous l'avez tous donné
beaucoup ce qu'elle a fait ce qu elle
est comme ça ce que je sais les marrons
de rechercher ce que tout le monde fuit
en fait vous recherchez la sunny side
est globalement les gens se battent pour
ne pas justement être seule voie choisie
la solitude c'est pas si grave
cette brèche saisies mais on ne sait pas
si cette souffrance est pas un abandon
un abandon affectif en fait c'est une
solitude enrichissante où l'on se
retrouve en fait avec soi même qui nous
aide à vivre pour le
le reste de la vie c'est des beaux
moments qu'on part chercher dans la
solitude et avec les y'a qu'en mer où on
peut avoir ce genre de sensations se
retrouver seul avec soi même mais bon on
n'est pas seul on se rend compte qu'on
est vraiment pas seul quand vous êtes
plaint pierre bâcher sait pas nager je
crois donc herbes hachées